[Music]
you play golf i understand i do and you
play golf with uh some celebrity pals
uh our normal foursomes me george lopez
sam jackson don cheadle oh yeah that's a
cool group hanging out with it is and we
have a tournament that we call the
brownie cup the brownie cup the brownie
cup because we're all black and brown so
we call it the brownie cup
and for other reasons can you can you
elaborate on the other reason it's
called the brownie cup yeah well one of
us has glaucoma
i'm not going to say which one one of us
has glaucoma sure sure you do well we'll
play uh pebble beach we'll play the
front nine uh regular yeah and then
somebody brings out their glaucoma
medicine
and um and then we play the back nine
dedicated okay
okay
so you play the front nine have some
medicine which is by the way i'm sure
there's a doctor's note involved oh of
course yes and then uh and you all share
it even though only one of you has
glaucoma yeah yeah
you know it's preventative care yeah for
those who don't yeah it's preventative
right sure that stuff is catching too
yes it is highly contagious disease oh
my god so you share your goal coming and
then you play uh you play the back nine
and then we have two shots of uh tequila
uh on the 12th hole and then we finish
it out and we count every stroke and
then you go to sleep
and we have a great trophy that we get
to keep for a year
and george won the first year i won the
second year and i keep my trophy on my
mantle uh next to my peabody for my work
on the shield and next to my nickelodeon
kids choice award award for best fart
for kangaroo jack
who's to say which is the superior award
you could say
uh i know you have kids how many kids do
you have two you have two kids uh how
involved are you in in their say their
extracurricular activities because i'm
i'm asking because my son he plays
t-ball i gotta be there for that he
plays basketball i gotta be there for
that you gotta start showing up for this
stuff what about you i'm very involved
uh you know i was my son's first coach
when he played football at six full full
contact and i wanted to be out there for
him and my daughter was the cheerleader
uh
she's 16 he's 12 now so she plays
volleyball in high school and my son
runs track so i there was this cheer
called the dynamite cheer that that i
would that i fell in love with so i just
took it as my own and i'm like the
official cheer dad at uh the functions
now you really go all out you do a
cheers i go all out i go all out even
when we fumble the ball i'll do the
dynamite chair it's so exciting okay
yeah and it's kind of i think i know the
dynamite cheer yeah no i mean i can do
it for you yeah i'd like to hear that
i'm gonna need your help sure
so
when i say my team is what i'm going to
need everybody in here to say dynamite
and then i'm going to say my team is
tick tick tick tick boom i want you to
say dynamite you got that yeah all right
all right all right hold on
all right our team is what
our team is what
our team is tick tick tick tick tick
tick tick
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm the black kid with nipples